hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode one in two
videos so lots of awesome Marvel Easter
eggs for the Cinematic Universe I'll try
to explain how it fits in with the
movies and the other TV shows you should
really think about this as being the
Marvel Cinematic Universe on TV not just
another Marvel TV show Kevin Feige
himself was editing an episode recently
so they brought out all their big guns
they had the same budget as a normal TV
show but they're only doing eight
episodes which means they could spend
more than twice as much on each episode
which is one of the reasons why it just
it looks so beautiful and they're able
to do such crazy stuff and I'll just say
up front that yet they did say that
they're planning on a season two so this
isn't like a one-time thing okay so
let's get going careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen
them yet
starting with top five moments number
five Avengers on screen
cranky O'Reilly isn't it awesome how
many Captain America scenes they
included in this they just totally went
for it how many times have we seen an
Avenger on screen in agents of shield
not a whole lot I mean we got Cobie
Smulders and Nick Fury but that's about
it
I've heard some rumors that that's gonna
change because of the Avengers 2 tie-in
that that shows gonna have but agent
Carter got there first just explain how
this show is connected to the MCU so
they're forming shield right now shield
was formed in 1946 the show takes place
in 1946 the place that Peggy's working
for though is still called the SSR that
gets folded into shield at a certain
point so I'm sure we'll see that happen
on screen all the nighttime missions all
that stuff that's covert that has
nothing to do with her official business
she's trying to clear starch name the
SSR is out to get him like they're just
looking for evidence to convict him then
you have all the stark tech so there's a
lot of visual references and the props
they use like that ball you know kind of
glowing like the tesseract all the
gadgets everything else that Howard
Stark is gonna develop as well as those
other pieces of lost technology that
were stolen from him then you have Anton
Vanko still apparently working with
Howard Stark I guess they haven't had
their falling out yet that we learned
about an Iron Man 2 in the comics Anton
actually is the one that becomes Crimson
Dynamo
like he's the first Crimson Dynamo so
small chance that we might see that on
screen sometime during this show if not
now then maybe during season 2 like that
that'd be awesome like it'd be a
prototype for the Iron Man suit because
the remember they developed the arc
reactor together he and Howard Stark a
lot of the characters we meet in the
organ is a
that we see end up turning into you know
Hydra or other big organizations inside
the Marvel Universe roxxon's a good
example so in the comics right now
there's a different president CEO ray
wise his character also another
comic-book person you know but from the
early Captain America comics they said
just just in general most of the stuff
that they're pulling from is from the
old Captain America comics or the old
comics of general although primarily
Captain America the showrunner said you
know just in general because of the time
period they're dealing with there so far
before all the stuff that's happening
right now they kind of have free reign
in terms of the stuff that they do from
the comics and the characters they use
there have been rumors of a Peggy Carter
appearance in the ant-man movie but that
hasn't been substantiated I don't have
any evidence on that so at this point
it's just speculation but once we get
through the eight episodes and we see
what they're building - presumably
that's gonna explain what the big point
of crossover is going to be so on one
level you know you have a lot of the
tie-in coming through this prequel of
sorts like the Gotham situation where
it's a prequel to all the Batman
villains that are coming then on another
level you have like literal crossover
where technology or devices formulas are
going to be involved in future movies
there are a couple of big Marvel
characters that could connect to
modern-day that they haven't done yet
but if they bring them on then it would
be like a direct point of crossover that
they could do so there's bear and blood
who gets involved in Doctor Strange
stuff later on you also have Human Torch
the original Human Torch remember we saw
his costume in the first Captain America
movie there's black panther in Wakanda
which is actually you know much more
important coming down the road I mean if
agents of shield is seating Inhumans the
movie at this point it's possible that
agent Carter could seed Black Panther
via Wakanda is just that in the Captain
America comics he runs into Black
Panthers father and grandfather
so it's possible we could see some of
Wakanda references there's Baron Zemo of
course it's just usually they say big
characters like that like he's a really
big character of masters of evil and
everything they usually save those
people for very very special things
Baron von Strucker was an enemy of the
Howling Commandos like in the old
Captain America comics but because he's
fairly young in current day I don't know
that they're necessarily gonna go in
that direction number four the Captain
America adventure hour sponsored by
Roxon this was just pure fun so like
whenever I was a little kid we would
take family car trips and
parents always listen to Garrison
Keillor so this actually kind of sounded
like a Garrison Keillor type thing
Prairie Home Companion style but how
cool is it that Roxon you know arguably
an evil organization in the Marvel
Universe is sponsoring these recaps
they're using it in a number of ways so
one they're using it to recap the action
at the beginning of episodes like this
is what you missed last time kind of
thing they're using it as a transitional
thing between scenes where they're just
like commenting on what's going on in
Peggy's life who writes this rubbish
it's almost like this supernatural force
that's just like commenting on what's
going on in any given moment and also
talks to the audience talks to us it's
like the voice of God and the MCU you
probably remember the adventure hour
from the first Captain America film when
they went on tour and he was trying to
sell war bonds so it's just another fun
thing that they pulled out of the movies
it's totally appropriate to the period I
thought it was really funny as long as
they don't use it too much I think it'll
be fun number three ray wise is the head
of Roxon but Leviathan is the big bad
there were a couple characters in this
that like the minute you saw them you
were like yeah this is not going to be a
good person have you ever seen ray wise
in something where he does not play a
villain same thing with James Frain so
this is a really big Easter Egg for the
Marvel Universe Roxon like the
corporation is directly responsible for
the death of Howard Stark and his wife
so Tony Stark's parents were killed by
Roxon but Roxon isn't a person Roxon is
just the name of the company his name is
Hugh Jones and he first appeared in
Captain America number 180 he got tied
up in this big serpent crown storyline
it was a big part of the early Captain
America comics and like a you know
Avengers crossovers the funny thing too
is that if you guys follow like the
Marvel announcements like they did their
big phase 3 announcement they did this
joke where they said before they said
that Captain America 3 was Civil War
they said it was gonna be serpent
Society that was that was like a big arc
from the early Captain America comics
they actually before they announced
Winter Soldier they did the exact same
thing - they said Captain America - is
gonna be serpent Society and it was just
like a joke like a fun joke for the fans
just Marvel trolling just a little bit I
like that he said that their point of
contention his and Starks point of
contention was his wife like stark had
sex with his wife so he just he hates
his guts so I already said I'm not
expecting him to be the big bad I think
he's going to be the person that they
just float in front of our faces he'll
be like the obvious villain
just like too obvious like the real
villain which turned out to be someone
else look forward to classic misdirect
wouldn't be crazy if he pulled out like
his own typewriter to like someone else
was giving him instructions all work and
no play make Marvel villains dull boys
just to explain who Leviathan is that's
actually an evil organization from the
comics but they weren't around during
that period in time so they're just
they're changing a little bit of that
Leviathan grew out of the Soviet Union
the same way that Hydra grew out of the
Nazi Party so it's like the Soviet Union
version of Hydra there was actually a
certain point in the comics where Hydra
and Leviathan worked together it was it
was like during the Secret Invasion
period number two real-life Jarvis so
James D'Arcy can't say enough about him
he's gonna be a lot of fun I'm not
really shipping these two characters
like I don't really get into that kind
of stuff but you could have some gift
fun with these two on tumblr Jarvis as
I've said in my other videos is the
inspiration for the AI Jarvis who
becomes vision eventually or at least
the voice of him becomes vision it's
really unclear like what the path
division is gonna be in Avengers age of
Ultron but what Emmy we'll find out it
just it's no coincidence that the voice
of Jarvis also becomes the vision that's
the Paul Bettany Jarvis though right now
while you're waiting for next week's
episode to come it'd be good time to go
back and watch the other Iron Man films
and listen to Tony talk to Jarvis in his
head Jarvis I got a run before I can
walk sometimes just like funny moments
that you could also lay onto agent
Carter scenes with Jarvis
for those wondering though this is 1946
Tony Stark wasn't born yet so we're not
gonna see like baby Robert Downey jr.
anytime soon on the show this is still
like a very young Howard Stark and yes I
totally got a vibe from his penthouse as
like a proto version of The Avengers
tower like Tony Stark's ultimate
bachelor pad and my number one moment
PEGI versus McPhee cut against the
Captain America flashbacks so the reason
I made this my number one is because
Peggy Carter obviously she had some
great fight scenes a lot of great action
scenes just in general this just cut
against that Captain America adventure
our play was so much fun her fight felt
like a good analog of the Captain
America opening scene from Winter
Soldier when he's on the boat and he
just Parker's the out of everyone
we made it really fun was the radio play
was like the dialogue from the radio
play it was like the woman screaming for
help from a man
like please come save me Captain America
but in this scene Peggy Carter is the
Captain America character like she's
fighting just as well as he did on that
boat just to be clear I mean he took
down like 50 people on less than three
minutes it was not like an equal amount
of force it was just meant to mirror
that moment as the title of the first
movie implies Captain America is the
First Avenger but Peggy Carter is also
an Avenger too in spirit so I'm really
looking forward to them building sort of
like a proto Avengers team so let me
know what was your favorite moment and
do you think that Roxon that Ray wisest
character is the big bad of the season
that he'll turn out to be connected to
Leviathan or do you think he's
completely unrelated so just some stray
observations some things I didn't
already mention so agent Sousa like her
friend there don't be surprised if he's
the person that she ends up getting
married to like wouldn't it be crazy if
it if it turned out that Captain America
saved him during the war then he came
back they end up working together he
eventually learns about what she's doing
they grow closer start a family so on
and so forth the residence history I
also feel like she's gonna win over Chad
Michael Murray in her boss her boss
Roger Dooley is another comic book
character like he was an early early
SHIELD agent and the old Captain America
comics I think I think at a certain
point the dudes will stop being
and they'll start helping her Angie
Martinelli the diner waitress that we
saw like we saw her more in the second
episode she's gonna be working with
Peggy Carter like doing her secret
extracurricular activities stuff she's
just way too sharp to be a normal person
and the really big thing Anton Vanko
still working with start I just I feel
like that's so awesome I feel like we're
gonna see some cool tech like some cool
stuff happen we might even get to see
their falling out a certain point like
in a future season I've already
mentioned the Crimson Dynamo stuff they
haven't really revealed what kind of
stark tech we're gonna see there's still
at least four or five other stark
inventions that are on the black market
overall I gave both episodes solid A's I
would say you know of all the TV shows
that I've done in this current season
this has had the strongest start I mean
era had a really strong start to you
know maybe maybe it's kind of a tie
between this and arrow I just I feel
like they're benefiting from the fact
that there's only eight episodes they're
just able to inject that much more
creativity just because they don't have
to fill all that extra time and they did
say if they get a season two they'll
probably gonna stick with eight episodes
like then I gotta go to 13 or
22 it doesn't really affect their budget
that much which is kind of weird I know
but small things so one of the
showrunners Tara butters is actually
married to the showrunner of arrow Marc
Guggenheim they did this really cool
interview where they kind of went back
and forth and joked and asked each other
really frank questions about running
both the shows and how they were
different how they were the same Marc
Guggenheim is written comics for both DC
and Marvel and stuff so he has a lot of
experience with Marvel even though
primarily right now he's a DC man let me
know what you guys think though do you
like that they're only doing 8 episodes
and just spending more money per episode
or would you like to see them do more
just to talk about the actors so there
is a reason why there are so many big
character actors in this like ray wise
for instance people like that it just
gives you an idea for how important
people think this is Haley Atwell did an
amazing job
Tara butters and her partner great
showrunners they wrote most of the
episodes too I mean there are other
writers they actually have staff writers
I'll be really interested to see how
they plotted the season out once we see
all eight episodes the look is
impeccable the action is great I feel
like this has better action than most
shows on television isn't it funny
though don't you feel like this show is
better than agents of shield already
they definitely are setting the bar like
I mean like I said Marvel Cinematic
Universe on TV not just another Marvel
TV show so it's like an 8 hour movie
that just airs on TV just in terms of
like characters in the comics they'll
have like a lot of Golden Age people
show up on the show it like people's
names like they'll give them names from
characters and the Golden Age of the
comics that doesn't necessarily mean
they're doing exact plots so they'll
like they'll mix and match things but
it's meant to kind of tie in with the
modern-day stuff so they'll just modify
backstories just so that it fits a
little bit better
they did say Marvel is allowing them to
do superpowers in the show but I don't
think that they did like they didn't say
that yes we do have a superpower person
on the show it seems like they wouldn't
give that away upfront though I just I
like that Marvel let them do that like
is it okay yeah if you want superpowers
you can use superpowers but as
showrunners it's up to them like they
were allowed to make that decision so if
you guys want I will do a Q&A for this
tomorrow I can do a live Q&A on my
twitch channel why don't we say I'll
stream starting around like 12 p.m.
Pacific time and I'll stay online for at
least like an hour in case anybody wants
to join the stream and ask me questions
they can be about anything - they don't
have to just be about agent Carter I do
have a couple other videos that I need
to get out though like I have a game of
Thrones video
Sherlock Christmas special videos next
week is episode three it's gonna be on
every night at 8 p.m. Eastern Time and I
do believe that Hulu is carrying
episodes so if you wait like a week you
should be able to watch it online
international people like if you're able
to watch Hulu like if you have a way to
do that okay so everybody get excited
Q&A coming soon I got a couple of their
bonus videos I'm gonna get through like
Sherlock Game of Thrones couple other
things in the meantime you can click
here for the ant-man trailer again in
case you haven't seen it yet and click
here to learn all about the dare devil
TV show thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I will see you
guys tomorrow
you